look what I did I'm Vanessa we are still
in bay area we're in Auckland visiting
with Chef Nelson chairman of Alomar
kitchen this is a restaurant that
actually showcases my roots it's not
really a cuisine per se I call it more
of a passion project I don't really hold
back on the flavors this is the best
seafood restaurant in town trust me so
we're making my mom's famous braised
dominican chicken it's delicious can be
over some rice a little bit of sweet
plantains this is very typical dish and
to make a republic but we're gonna do a
little bit of strip twists add some more
spices to it this is our beautiful dark
meat chicken and it's already been
marinated for 24 hours I have some
spices there is lemon pepper seasoning
we have cilantro we have an orange we're
gonna use the zest you can hear it
sizzling already I'm in the happy the
reason I did Dominican is to showcase my
roots and just cuz it's my first
restaurant I want to showcase Who I am
remember we're gonna be brazing so
brazing is basically the technique of
cooking something in the liquid slow and
oh so now we're gonna add our chicken
stock everything is gonna get tender and
that's the reason you do a low heat at
least an hour now we're gonna add our
secret ingredient the sofrito
so the sofrito is a blend of different
greetings red onions garlic cilantro
olive oil salt pepper
and usually my mom uses green bell
peppers and we use that as a marinade
for the chicken we're also going to take
something to use in the sauce I'm really
loving that you're adding citrus
it does something to the dish actually
brightens it up which is amazing that
comes from that boldness that we love in
our food and while you're doing that I
have my cilantro oh my mom loves to do
is just pick it over it distorting the
pot high-five yeah we were always a
full-service restaurant but the
restaurant industry especially in the
bay is getting a lot harder I decided to
make it fast casual and we're slowly
becoming a neighborhood spot you know
giving out great food great service of
places where you can have fun and just
enjoy yourself and you won't break your
pockets about ten there that is I was
like falling apart so I'm gonna put the
plaintiff right up here okay loan me
some plantains so the biggest compliment
for me as a chef was getting a mission
of recommendation to get that first
letter in our first year being opened
was an amazing feeling this is a hey
we're watching I really want to try some
of us with the bright Opress I gotta
have it
now have a cool bite
I think this is the best play of
checking off of your head thank you
and so with the lemon and the cabbage
and the really big orange on major
looseness rather you taste the crunchy
and this is the year this was absolutely
amazing what an experience the fact that
you can take few ingredients and just
make something with so much flavor
definitely coming back here thank you so
much chef I really enjoyed experiencing
all the food and cultures and how you
put that into your food with love let's
impress here in the Bay Area see you
next time on tasty for chasing our roof
[Music]
you
[Music]